what's up Lawrence - sure what's up guys
not even lowering our year high so we're
gonna check out the trailer for dope
what's cooler than I just kind of do
you're a really good role model kids I
know a lot of you guys are kids out
there who watch this channel medical
marijuana is the way to go enjoy dope
don't know what it's about but I know
for us Twitter Kurt is in it he's the
guy with the loopy eye yeah what do you
think you are
zoe kravitz I've never wanted to dance
so much I have no idea what that was
about I think it's about a musical
artist in like the late 80s and early
90s I mean the trailers not clear but
this trailer is really communicating its
style to it you know and I feel like
they're talking about the world at the
time you know maybe the storyline is not
so clear in this trailer but I like all
the 90s graphics I like all the 90s fun
themes the music does sound dope it's
really cool [ __ ] night
I enjoyed the trailer and it makes me
wanna makes me want to know what Forest
Whitaker's doing in this movie because I
mean it was not gonna change he's
probably that kid's dad that's why I
guess I don't think that I think about
that's funny about this trailer is how
they shot it it's basically like they
have a shot that's like Pokemon and they
have like them super Mario or was that
original Mario whatever he's like
playing he's like collecting the coins
and stuff but I feel like the way that
the trailer is filmed it's actually
catering towards kids today while those
references are catering to people
outraged oh that's smart
that is smart good job movie studios
right yeah because it's like everything
was just like little cutaways the thing
I love Instagram all I want to do is
scroll through pictures like I don't
want to like sit in for two minutes and
watched a video about a story I just
want to flip through and see these
different things which is like when I
feel this trailer is ya know absolutely
I like just the fun vibe that they're
having going for it you know like I
haven't seen a movie that's like really
gonna honor that era with such style
before and I'm hoping it has that kind
of level of styling like even the few
shingles the few shots we got
I like the angles of it I mean the one
thing that makes me nervous is that the
fact that they don't really show a lot
of cliffs in the movie which makes me
think that maybe it's not a very good
movie oh that's true like when they
don't tell you what the movies about in
the trailer makes me feel like the movie
isn't about anything same time this is
the first trailers are usually a second
trailer will get more storyline I mean
that's true just to me this this looks
like a representation of like the life I
live on the streets in front of Randy's
donut if I Randy's Donuts you know
people say I'm a geek but I'm into music
and you know like I want to be able to
do more but at the same time I come from
the streets you are basically living
this movie I'm basically the movie they
took the door story to write this movie
they you should suit I should sue them
anyway guys thanks for mentioning that
trailer was out if you're new to the
channel you know what you can do you're
gonna subscribe you can check out Lauren
Goss channel [ __ ] on there and there's
none of that and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
we're Lauren's always tweeting like a
big dick today and then she instagrams a
photo of a big dick and then she
publishes it to Facebook and she's like
check out the big dick I posted on
Instagram pretty spot-on yeah that's my
Lauren impression I do have a really
deep boy I love deer my name is Lauren
go